[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hey everybody how you doing pete stanlow
here looking to give you all here a
little first look video of a game called
ragnarium uh i think that's how you
pronounce it i'm not 100 positive uh it
is a
uh like a city builder type game uh
where you're placed on a
on a desolate planet uh and you are
looking to survive and thrive there with
your colonists now
uh we were given this uh key via the
email uh the email from the company and
um the company's name i'm sorry but i'm
blanking on at this time
um so a couple different things i want
to talk about
one this game is early access
so
they're
there was a lot of things in there that
was missing
uh but still
i think that they have a lot
a lot of potential on this game
now
the reason that i'm i'm kind of okay
with this game is because
it is early access
now
when you are playing a game for instance
like rimworld and you're placing a
decimal planet like that it's very
simplistic
meaning you know you have to build your
town you kind of grow out your town
and then after that you defend your town
and you're kind of good to go
um now the problem with with regularium
is that you are essentially this planet
to be colonized
it took me a little while to figure out
how
to kind of go through the process of you
know
getting myself to to do the colonization
before you send your your people there
you get to pick who goes there so you
could pick you know uh soldiers you know
colonists i'm sorry scientists
uh so on and so forth to kind of put you
through
uh through that town uh to kind of get
you get them all onto the onto your
craft you send your craft you tell them
where to land
i thought that was really really a cool
concept though especially
telling your people where to land and
things like that i thought that was
really really cool
now the thing
a couple of things i wanted to bring up
and bring to
you know their attention
number one
uh the tutorial system i feel like
needed to be
vastly more
you know upkeep and a lot more you know
improved i was very confused with the
game i had to restart it twice to kind
of figure out where i was going once i
kind of understood what i was doing
i was like okay i'm kind of streamlining
this a little better
the crafting system is very very
confusing to interact with that if they
you know put in a tutorial system and
kind of told you how to do that then
thumbs up
you know i could end up doing that
that'd be fantastic
now as for the
the colonists
the what's cool about the colonists are
that you can upgrade their weapons you
can upgrade their armor
they actually have their own
individualized skill bases that go up
uh and
which is something that is i feel is
very different in comparison to other
other uh
other games like this um and you can
actually take your columns send them out
on quests you send them out on a quest
they end up you know
completing your quest and then end up
coming back and uh you know gain
increased xp
or they could unlock a new schematic for
crafting uh and things like that
so they have a really really really
uh great concept with with the colonists
and i think that that over time if they
take it they can definitely use they
could definitely use it to kind of
improve and i think that those are going
to be really really cool
now
what i thought was really interesting
was that
you can like
plant new trees and over time you know
they'll grow and use them to pull them
down for
for whatever you need
uh the fact that you know there are you
know ai just places around the world
that you can go fight and attack and
then they'll give you some type of
reward and xp for your colonists was
kind of cool
so
it had a lot of different types of you
know little elements on it that was
really good
now
the
the gameplay on it was uh like i said it
was a little clunky because they need a
tutorial for it
uh the graphics on it were
were okay
um you could tell this was a company
just you know starting to kind of go
through the process of learning how to
do it i think that of uh you know if
they get smoother images and i think
that if they take a little bit of time
they can definitely definitely complete
that
uh the next thing is uh you know the
sounds the sounds on it
they were kind of all right i mean
i'm hoping that they have a more robust
robust uh robust sound you know library
when they get into the you know into
full line production
and i think that it's gonna have a lot
of really really cool uh you know
capabilities going further
now um
as for replayability um
where the game stands right now
i for me personally i i i have to wait
until let's see if they can you know put
a little bit more improvements in it and
then i'll then i'll definitely hop in
and take a look at it again
uh as for the
the looking of the game
um and if you wanted to replay it the
coolest part about it is that you know
you pick your beginning colonists and
you send them out and you know they do
their work and they figure out what's
going on and then they'll send it off
um i want you all to know that you know
the videos that you're watching it's
probably pretty quiet in comparison to
my other videos i did this offline uh i
wanted to make sure i got it you know
done and recorded and ready to go uh so
i did a really really late one night
when uh when everybody was asleep so
uh it wasn't live at the time but we did
end up taking our time to play it um
so it was good oh i forgot i wanted to
tell you um
something that was kind of cool about
the uh
this game uh did there are little like
points of interest throughout the whole
entire
uh
map when you go there and you complete
them you know you could get something
like minerals or materials or weapons or
even other colonists which i thought was
really really cool because if you get
other colonists then you know your town
will grow and you know you can work
through that but you know there's also
positive negatives with that because
then you gotta you know
feed them and things like that so yeah
uh just something i wanted to make sure
that you knew about okay so anyway um
this is once again uh ragnarium um you
know check it out on steam uh my name is
pete also knows naldo i'm on twitch uh
five days a week from monday to friday
from 3 p.m eastern time to 11 p.m
eastern time uh you know you come check
us out you can always hit the follow hit
the comment button here uh if you are uh
you know if you want to go check out the
iron alerts podcast make sure you go
check them out on sundays uh now and
also for any of your gaming needs please
make sure you go to lordsofgaming.net
uh they are you know there every day
publishing amazing articles
uh once again my name is sneldo that's
s-n-a-l-y-d-o-t-v
uh and uh you know go check us out so
thank you again and i hope to see you
and speak to you soon all right thank
you bye everybody
oh
colonists are engaging enemies
foreign
don't you look at me
objective completed commander
incoming transmission
[Music]
you